if you have a minute today check out
Bloomberg politics calm but if you only
have 30 seconds today check out the
chris christie campaigns second TV ad
protect america the subject iran the
imagery scary president obama gave away
the store the Iranians to a group of
people who since 1979 I've been chanting
death to America this was negotiated so
bad with that you wouldn't let this
president buy a car for you a car
dealership and so as president the top
priority is to protect the United States
of America and I'm the only one in this
race had it be some small part of that
responsibility I'm chris Christie and I
approve this message mark what does it's
where I it's crazy what is this ad say
about big boys we like to call him about
himself about his view of the his rivals
and his view of the electorate I can't
believe mr. definitive says I'm the only
one who had at least some experience who
would have thought that chris Christie
would order to add at this point on
national security now I'm mr. take
charge mr. top I get that but but every
Republicans polling data is finding
these are big themes with Republicans
that should agree but I can't believe
that this is what chris Christie thinks
he's going to run and widows given is
given the fact that he doesn't really
have that much experience referring to
his time as us a trying dealings unless
yours am I mean look they're ours by
five count them force US senators who
will probably all stand up and have
their heads explode when they think that
Chris Christie's claiming he has more
foreign policy experience than they do
also just the that scowl on his face I
mean it that is I mean that is not
straight that's not speech that's a
strength that's sort of scary more than
this but there's no doubt that because
Hillary Clinton is seen as having
commander-in-chief credentials the
secretary everybody's got to run on that
Republican voters care a lot about